[موسيقى]
بتوقيت الرياض انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
[موسيقى]
وسط ترقب لهجوم الربيع اوكرانيا تؤكد ان
روسيا بدات مناورات واسعه لقواتها النوويه
تزامنا مع زياره بايدن لاوروبا
وتدرس ارسال اسلحه لروسيا وكبير
الدبلوماسيين الصينيين في موسكو غدا
المنظمات الدوليه توجه نداء عاجلا لزياده
مساعدات مناطق سوريا المنكوبه واكثر من
اربعه ملايين في خطر جديد
شركه ميتا الملكه لفيسبوك تعلن اطلاق خدمه
مسبقه الدفع لتوثيق الحسابات على غرار
تويتر
[موسيقى]
وصلتم اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
البدايه مما اوردته الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه ان القوات النوويه
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه اجرت مناورات واسعه
تزامنا مع زياره الرئيس الامريكي الى
اوروبا واعتبر اوكرانيا ان المناورات
الروسيه هدفها اضعاف الدعم الدولي
لاوكرانيا ومنع زياره بايدن المقرره غدا
الى القاره الاوروبيه واوضحت الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه ان القوات النوويه الروسيه
استعدت برا وبحرا وجوا واجرت فحصا لنظام
التحكم القتالي اضافه لصواريخ كروس
اتهمت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اوكرانيا
بانها تخطط لهجوم نووي على اراضيها لتحميل
موسكو مسؤوليته قبل اجتماع للامم المتحده
وقالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انما وادى
مشعه تم نقلها الى اوكرانيا من دوله
اوروبيه وان كيف تستعد لعمل استفزازي واسع
النطاق واضافت الدفاع الروسيه ان الهدف من
الخطه هو اتهام الجيش الروسي بشن هجمات
عشوائيه مزعومه على منشات مشعه خطيره في
اوكرانيا مما يؤدي الى تسرب مواد مشعه
وحدوث تلوث في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
ميدانيه نفذ اعلام الروسي باجلاء السكان
من ضواحي باخموت في دنياسك بسبب قصف
اوكرانيا واعلن عمده مدينه دنيتك المؤيد
لروسيا عن ايقاف عمل المواصلات العامه في
المدينه في مدينه تحسبا لتطورات القصف
الاوكراني بعد استهداف مناطق متفرقه من
المدينه باربعون باربعين صاروخ فامباير
تشيكيا وخمس قذائفنت كما شمل القصف مدافع
واسفر عن اصابه شخصين واضرار ماديه
تحول القوه الاوكرانيه تجهيز نفسها وتسابق
الزمن من خلال التدريب جنودها والحصول على
المزيد من الاسلحه الغربيه المتقدمه
استعدادا لمواجهه هجوم الروسي المحتمل
خلال الربيع المقبل بعد سنه من القتال
الذي لم يحسم الصراع لصالح اي من الطرفين
عجله الحرب في اوكرانيا لا تتوقف عن
الدوران فصول اربعه عاشتها المعركه في
انتظار فصل خامس
كيف تستعد لصد هجوم روسي محتمل خلال
الربيع
هجوم يسبقه تكتيك روسي جديد يتمثل في
اطلاق مناطيد تحمل عاكسات رادار فوق
اوكرانيا للحصول على معلومات بشان انظمه
الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني لاجبار كياف على
استنزاف مخزوناتها القيمه من الذخيره
وصواريخ ارض جو حسب الدفاع البريطانيه
لمواجهه ذلك الاوكرانيون فتحوا خطه تعبئه
طوعيه جديده وفق صحيفه الطعام الصحيفه
ذاتها نقلت عن مستشار زيلينسكي قوله ان
معركه السيطره على باخموت مهمه وان
اوكرانيا لن تتخلى عنها ابدا اذ تعتبرها
مفتاح الصراع ولا مجال لخسارتها فالسيطره
على باخموت ستشكل نقطه انطلاق بالنسبه
لروسيا للزحف نحو مدينتين اكبر هما اكرم
تورسك اللتين تقعان ابعد باتجاه الغرب في
دونيتسك ما سيعيد الزخم قبل الذكرى الاولى
لانطلاق الحرب ولتحقيق هذا الهدف تطالب
اوكرانيا حلفائها الغربيين بالمزيد من
الطائرات المقاتله والدبابات الحربيه
المتقدمه في وقت تؤكد كياف انها تحتاج
ايضا صواريخ بعيده المدى لصد الهجوم
الروسي واستعاده السيطره على المناطق التي
خسرتها فالجيش الاوكراني يستهلك القذائف
بوتيره اسرع مما يمكن للغرب ان يصنع حسب
رويترز ما يمثل عقبه اخرى امام قوتكياف
خلال المرحله المقبله بلال الوجداني
العربيه
[موسيقى]
نقلت صحيفه بوليتيكو عن مسؤولين امريكيين
قولهم ان اداره رئيس جو بايدن طلبت من
اوكرانيا تعزيز مكاسبها والاستعداد لشن
هجوم مضاد على روسيا اوضح المسؤولون ان
اداره بايدن تتخوف من عدم قدرتها على
ارسال مساعدات الى اوكرانيا بسبب
الجمهوريين واشار المسؤولون الامريكيون
الى ان مساعدي بايدن بحثوا زيارته
لاوكرانيا ثم تم استبعاد الفكره
نتابع من مع حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه
حذيفه اهلا بك معنا بدايه هلا وضعتنا في
سوره اخر التطورات الميدانيه اليوم في
عموم اوكرانيا
تحياتي صهيب بحسب بيان هيئه الاركان
العامه المشتركه الاوكرانيه فقط نفذ الروس
اليوم 9 ضربات صاروخيه على مناطق مختلفه
نتحدث عن تحديدا واخرستون كذلك نفذوا 11
ضربه جويه
ونفذوا ايضا 20 ضربه براجمات الصواريخ في
مناطق متفرقه بالمقابل القوات الاوكرانيه
نفذت 20 ضربه جويه كما اتى في بيان هيئه
الاركان المشتركه انها نفذت في مناطق
لتمركز الاليات والمدرعات والجنود وانظمه
الدفاع الجوي وايضا قالت انها نفذت ضربتين
في ما وصفه البيان بمنطقتين هامتين ولم
تفصح عن ما يتمركز في تلك المناطق سهيل
نعم هذا ميدانيا كذلك حذيفه كان لافتا ان
التلويح بالنووي من قبل روسيا يعود من
جديد الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن
مناورات روسيه
بالقوات النوويه الاستراتيجيه الروسيه
تزامنا مع الزياره المرتقبه للرئيس بايدن
الى اوروبا هل هناك المزيد من التفاصيل
حول ما كشفته الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه
نعم في الحقيقه اليوم تحدث
فريدروفيسكي وهو عضو اللجنه الامن والدفاع
والاستخبارات في البرلمان
البرلمان الاوكراني وقال انهم لا يستبعدون
اي تنفيذ اي نوع من انواع الضربات من قبل
الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكن هذا سيكون حل اخير
بالنسبه للاتحاد الروسي تحدث عن مخاوف
اوكرانيا الامنيه في الوقت الحالي وقال ان
الدفاعات في جميع الاتجاهات هي جيده
وصامده وان الاتحاد الروسي غير قادر على
اختراقها او الزحف نحو العاصمه كيف طبعا
هو يتحدث عن الذكرى السنويه ويعني الحديث
الذي يدور حول اجتياح كامل للاراضي
الاوكرانيه طبعا لم ينفي انه سوف تنفذ
عمليات سماها هو بالارهابيه في المناطق
المدنيه وقال انه سوف يكون هنالك اطلاق
صواريخ ولكن لا نتوقع ان تكون عمليه اطلاق
الصواريخ تتعدل 100 صاروخ لان الروس لا
يملكون في الوقت الحالي المخزون الكافي
لتنفيذ ضربه تتعدى ذلك ايضا قال انه سوف
يكون هنالك ضربات بالط ائرات المسيره شاهد
وايضا قال انها لن تتعدى المئه طائره ولكن
عمليه الاستخدام النووي والتلويح بالنووي
في الوقت الراهن هم لا يتوقعون ان تنفذ
ضربات ولكنهم يرصدون التحرك السفن في
البحر الاسود وكذلك المناورات التي تمت
بالطائرات القادره على حمل صواريخ تحمل
الرؤوس النوويه حذيفه عادل منكيف شكرا
جزيلا
طرف اخر قد يدخل دائره الحرب في اوكرانيا
من خلال دعم روسيا بالاسلحه والاتهام هذه
المره قادم من واشنطن فوزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه نفسه اكد ان الصين تخطط لارسال
اسلحه الى روسيا وكشف بلنكن ان الصين تقدم
دعما ماديا لروسيا وتدرس تحويلها هذا
الدعم الى عسكري بلنكن هدد ايضا الصين
بتحمل عواقب وخيمه اذا اقدمت على تسليح
موسكو اثناء حربها في اوكرانيا
لقد كنا قلقين منذ اليوم الاول بشان هذا
الاحتمال وحتى الان راينا شركات صينيه
وبالطبع في الصين لا يوجد فرق بين الشركات
الخاصه والتابعه للدوله رايناهم يقدمون
دعما دون اسلحه قتاليه لروسيا لاستخدامه
في اوكرانيا ان القلق الذي يساوينا الان
يستند الى معلومات لدينا تفيد بانهم
يفكرون في تقديم دعم قاتل وقد اوضحنا لهم
ان ذلك من شانه ان يسبب مشكله خطيره في
علاقاتنا
هذه الاتهامات الامريكيه الموجهه الى لم
تتوقف عند هذا الحد بل امتدت الى حدود
صراع الفضاء الجوي بهذا الخصوص قال
الجنرال تشانس قائد عمليات الفضاء في سلاح
الجو الامريكي قال ان الفضاء شهد تحولا
جوهريا في غضون سنوات قليله بسبب سباق
التسلح المضطرد معتبرا ان الصين تشكل
تهديد الاكبر في الفضاء
وبالعوده لا تصريحات بلينكن فاقت شكلت
اتهاما مباشرا وصريحا هو الاول من نوعه ضد
الصين فيما يخص ملف تسليح روسيا ورغم ان
الشائعات حول امكانيه دعم الصين لروسيا
بالاسلحه ظهرت منذ فتره الا ان البنتاغون
كان دائما ينفي وجود الدليل على تصدير
الصين للاسلحه الى روسيا او عزمها القيامه
بذلك وكانت صحيفه الاول من تحدث عن
الموضوع من خلال نشر تقرير يفيد ان الصين
تزود روسيا في حربها باوكرانيا بكل ما
تحتاجه القوات الروسيه من التكنولوجيا
الصينيه
ووفقا لصحيفه الامريكيه فان موسكو تجهز
مقاتلاتها وغواصاتها وجنودها بمساعده
الشركات الصينيه
مو سيارات صينيه تنشرها روسيا على الخطوط
الاماميه في الحرب مع اوكرانيا ترفع مستوى
القلق الغربي لاكثر من سبب حسب وسط جون
روسيا التي دابت على استخدام هذه المسيرات
تواصل شرائها من الشركات المصنعه في الصين
عبر طرف ثالث لتلتف بذلك على العقوبات
الغربيه
حذر من ان هذه الطائرات المسيره الصينيه
لا تغذي فقط المجهود الحربيه الروسي فهي
ذات استخدام مزدوج تسمح ايضا للصين بجمع
معلومات استخباراتيه حاسمه من ساحه
المعركه قد تعزز استعدادات بكير لاي حرب
مستقبليه كما ان تستغل الفرصه لاختبار مدى
تاثر هذه المسيرات بهجمات الحرب
الالكترونيه من اجل تحسين قدراتها مستقبله
بالنسبه الى كيف الهاجس الاساسي من هذه
المسيرات الصينيه هو ان روسيا تستخدمها من
اجل توجيه افضل للصواريخها باتجاه الاهداف
الاوكرانيه
مع هذه التطورات حضر وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن بكين من الذهاب
ابعد وتوعدها بعواقب وخيمه اذا ارسلت
اسلحه الى روسيا
الى ان المعلومات المتوفره لدى واشنطن
تؤكد ان تدرس تحويل دعمها المادي لروسيا
الان الى الدعم العسكري
التحذيرات الامريكيه تسبق زياره وفد صيني
رفيع المستوى الى موسكو وصفته الاخيره
بانه لتعميق الشراكه بين البلدين
هذا ويزور غدا الاثنين كبير الدبلوماسيين
الصينيين وانجي يزوروا موسكو بعد جوله
اوروبيه اعلن خلالها خطه صينيه للسلام في
اوكرانيا ووفقا للمتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الصينيه فان زياره وانجي لروسيا ستوفر
فرصه للبلدين لمواصله تطوير الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه وتبادل وجهات النظر حول
القضايا الدوليه والاقليميه ذات الاهتمام
المشترك ولم تحدد وزاره الخارجيه ما اذا
كان كبير الدبلوماسيين الصينيين سيلتقي
بالرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
معنى من موسكو المحلل السياسيه
اهلا بك معنا ما رايك في تصريحات وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي الذي قال ان الصين تنظر
في دعم روسيا بالسلاح
هذا الكلام الذي قاله برينكن ليس في جديد
لانه الصين اتهمت بتزويد روسيا ببعض انواع
الاسلحه بما فيها الصواريخ وحتى الصواريخ
البالستيه العابره للقارات منذ 11 شهرا اي
بعد بدايه العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
شهر واحد انا زايد كان هناك نفي قاطع من
قبل روسيا لمثل هذه الامدادات وهي لم
تتاكد في وقت لاحق من قبل اي بلد او اي
مصدر سواء كان عسكري
روسيا هي تحشد قواتها خاصه في دنيتك
استعدادا لمصطلح عليه بمعركه الربيع او
الهجوم الكبير مع الثانويه الاولى للعمليه
العسكريه او الحرب في اوكرانيا وغدا هناك
زياره لوانغي كبير الدبلوماسيين الصينيين
الى موسكو
الا يؤكد هذا على انه فعلا روسيا هي بحاجه
للمزيد من الدعم العسكري لتحقيق هدفها من
العمليه العسكريه
في الحقيقه هذا ما سنعرفه اولا
الى موسكو وهي كما يبدو تاتي كذلك في اطار
الاستعداد لزياره الرئيس الصيني
الى روسيا والمقرر القيام بها ربما بعد
عده اسابيع او على الاقل في خلال الربيع
المقبل واعتقد بانه اذا تم اتخاذ اي قرار
بهذا الشان فسوف يعلن عنه فقط بعد هذه
الزياره او ستكون هناك ربما بعد التسريبات
حول هذا الموضوع الان من المبكر جدا
الحديث عامه اذا كانت الصين بالفئه
العاصمه على تزويد روسيا بمختلف والاسلحه
التي تحتاج اليها ربما روسيا في اوكرانيا
شكرا جزيلا لك
مباشره من موسكو
[موسيقى]
خلال فتره الحرب مشاهدينا تفرض حراسه
مشدده على زعماء البلدان المتحاربه الامر
لا يختلف بالنسبه للرئيسين الروسي
والاوكراني بين قطار بوتين المدرع ومخبا
ايزيلنسكي السري تباينت وسائل الحمايه في
وقت تستمر فيه المعارك الضاريه
قطار بوتين المدرع وملجا زيلينسكي تحت
الارض بين كياف وموسكو اختلفت وسائل
الحمايه المخصصه لزعيم البلدين زمن الحرب
بوتين يستعمل القطار خلال تنقلاته في جميع
انحاء روسيا والوصول الى قصوره الخاصه
القطار مطلي باللونين الاحمر والرمادي ما
يجعله كاي قطار ركاب عادي هو عباره عن
عربه رئاسيه بها غرفه نوم بالاضافه الى
مقصوره مجهزه بمعدات الاتصالات المتطوره
كلف بناؤه اكثر من 13 مليون دولار يقال ان
الرئيس الروسي مقتنع بان السفر فيه اكثر
امانا من ركوب الطائرات التي يسهل تتبعها
الحكايه مختلفه في كييف زيليسكي يحتمي تحت
الارض في مخبا سري يطلق عليه اسمو بانكوفا
وهو كتله خرسانيه من المكاتب المحاطه
بحلقه من الفولاذ تصطف حوله نقاط مع حراس
مسلحين لا يسمحون بدخول اي شخص سوى من
لديهم تصريح بذلك ويطلب الجنود من
الموجودين كلمات مرور سريه تتغير يوميا
وغالبا ما تكون عبارات يصعب على الروس
نطقها استخدمه زيلينسكي واعضاء حكومته
خلال سيطره الجيش الروسي على بلدات مجاوره
بعد ذلك تغيرت الخطه وخرج زيلينسكي ومن
معه بلال الوجداني العربيه
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
يؤكد ان اسرائيل لن تسمح لايران بامتلاك
اسلحه النوويه ويتعهد برد شديد على اي
هجمات
[موسيقى]
القسطره القلبيه العلاجيه
وجراحات القلب
على مدار 24 ساعه
بمستشفيات المواساه
المواساه خبره تنبض بالثقه
[موسيقى]
طلبها كانت القوه العسكريه هي احدى
العوامل المحوريه المؤثره
في قوه الدول
وحسن الصراعات
ولعل قاده العالم
يدركون مدى تاثيرها
[موسيقى]
فقد يعرفون اسرارا لا نعرفها فمن يتحكم
بموازين القوى وكيف تدار الصفقات
جدير بناء ان نسال وان نجد اجابات
للسلعه الاكثر اهميه وتعقيدا وتنافسا في
العالم
عسكري تاريا السبت العاشره والنصف على
شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
نبض السوق
في هذه الاوقات على الشاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد لا تزال النكبات تلاحق
السوريين فما نجا من الحرب الدائره في
الداخل قضى تحت انقاذ زلزال المدمر
والمناطق التي هزها زلزال في تركيا كانت
تضم اعدادا كبيره من اللاجئين السوريين
وبلغه الارقام فان عدد اللاجئين السوريين
الذين فقدوا حياتهم في تركيا جراء الزلزال
بلغ سته الاف ومائه لاجئ وذلك نقلا عن
صحيفه قرار التركيه
وتمركز اغلب القتل السوريين في تركيا في
مدن غازي عنتاب هاتاي وكرمان مراش كما تضم
المدن التي وقع فيها الزلزال عددا كبيرا
من السوريين ايضا حيث تعد مدينه غازي
عنتاب ثاني اكبر مدينه تركيه تضم لاجئين
سوريين بعد اسطنبول فقبل الزلزال كانت تضم
اي غازي عنتاب اكثر من 460 الف لاجئ سوري
فيما تاتي في المركز الثالث مدينه هاتاي
والتي تضم ازيد من 430 الف لاجئ سوري هذا
في الوقت الذي يقيم فيه ازيد من 95 الف
لاجئ سوري في مدينه كرماش وفي احصائيه
اكثر دقه فان عدد الضحايا من الذين
السوريين الذين قضوا جراء زلزال بلغ نحو
خمس مجموع الضحايا الذين سقطوا في تركيا
والذين تج اوزوا الاربعين فقط
حركه النشطه عرفتها الحدود التركيه
السوريه بعد وقوع الزلزال من خلال دخول
الشاحنات المساعدات ونقل الضحايا فضلا عن
عوده الكثير من اللاجئين الى سوريا بشكل
طوعي بعد النكبات التي المت بهم وبلغ عدد
اللاجئين السوريين الذين دفنوا في تركيا
حوالي ثلاثه الاف وثمانمائه فيما بلغ عدد
من نقلت جثامينهم للدفن في سوريا
[موسيقى]
اما فيما يتعلق باعداد العائدين فقد بلغت
10,333 سوريا عادوا الى بلادهم بشكل طوعي
بعد الزلزال
نتابع من اسطنبول مع اوكتاريا الماز
المحلل السياسي سيد اوكتاي اهلا بكم معنا
عما ابانا الزلزال برايك وهذه الازمه
الانسانيه عن علاقه الاتراك بالسوريين
تحيه طيبه
مساء الخير نعم الزلزال او الافه الطبيعيه
لا تفرق طبعا بين
المواطن او الاجنبي
والمصيبه واحده حقيقه يعني كما ذكرتم في
هناك ارقام يعني حسب علمي وحسب ما اخذت من
المعلومات من الميدان حوالي 20% من
المتضررين من السوريين اللاجئين
يعني
على المقاطعه لكن قبل الزلزال كنا بدانا
نسمع بعض الاصوات وبعض المظاهر التي يعني
فيها نوع من العنصريه ضد الوجود السوري في
تركيا صراحه يعني ما دام انه الازمه
الانسانيه لا تفرق الزلزال لم يفرق بين
تركي وسوري هل زالت هذه النظره هذا التوجه
ام لا برايك
سيدي الكريم يعني
القط تكون العنصريه لدى البعض وهذه قله
جدا ولكن المشاكل الناجمه من كثره
السوريين وما الى ذلك هناك تداعيات طبعا
لوجودهم يعني لا اصفها بالعنصريه يعني
شكايه المواطن عن بعض
التداعيات لا تعتبر العنصريه لو كانت
العنصريه لم تقبل الاتراك منذ البدايه
السوريين هذه الشكاوى وهذه المشاكل زادت
مع
مع طول الوقت وما اعطيت الكبير ومع عدم
تقطيع
السلطاني هذه المصيبه
الجميع
الحكومه التركيه تتجه لتعويض المتضررين
يعني ست وجه الرئيس اردوغان قال انه يخصص
اموالا لتعويض الذين فقدوا منازلهم هل
يعني سيكون هذا في الحسبان حتى اللاجئين
السوريين يعني بنفس المنطق سيكون لهم
تعويضات برايك ام لا نعم
بكل تاكيد قبل المجيء الى برنامجكم تحدثوا
السوريين في المنطقه المعنيين بالشؤون
اللاجئين اكدوا لي ان اللاجئين السوريين
يستفيدون من جميع
الامكانيات التي تستفيد منها المواطن
التركي المنكوب يعني الحكومه التركيه
السلطات التركيه في المنطقه في المناطق
المنكوبه لا تفرق بين المواطنين واللاجئ
او الاجنبي ما تقدموا للمواطن من الطعم
والمساعده والنجده والامكانيات تقدمها
كذلك للعجين المقيمين من الخيام من الماوى
والمشرب وعطى
الدفع الماديه هناك كذلك مساعدات للاجئين
للايجار وما الى ذلك
لا تفريق بهذا الخصوص
شكرا جزيلا لك من اسطنبول
تركيا وسوريا لم يخلف ضحايا ودمارا فحسب
بل ترك اثارا عميقه لدى الاشخاص وحاله من
الرعب والذعر جثمت على نفوس الكثيرين حمى
الخوف من الزلزال اجتاحت مختلف ربوع تركيا
بما في ذلك كبرى مدن البلاد اسطنبول حاله
من الرعب تعيشها مدينه اسطنبول في ظل
تداول بعض الاخبار عن امكانيه وقوع زلزال
قوي في المدينه اخبارنا وان كانت غير
دقيقه بالشكل الكافي الا انها دفعت العديد
من السكان في اسطنبول الى الدخول في حاله
تاهب لمواجهه اي زلزال مرتفع اذا هي مظاهر
عديده تعكس حاله التاهب هاته لدى السكان
في اسطنبول فالعديد من الاسر هبت الى شراء
الاحتياجات الضروريه في حاله وقوع زلزال
من البطانيات الحراريه والخيام الصغيره
والمصابيح التي تعمل بالبطاريات كما بدا
كثير من ملاك العقارات التفكير في اجراء
اختبارات لقوه تحمل المباني للزلازل هذا
وتفاعلت بلديه المدينه مع حاله الرعب هذه
حيث بادرت الى اطلاق حمله لهدم المباني
القديمه التي يعود تاريخ انشائها لعام 99
كما بات بامكان المواطنين في اسطنبول
التقدم بطلب لفحص المبنى او تجديده بعد
الاتفاق مع جميع سكانه عبر رابط مخصص لذلك
والتخوفات الكبيره من حدوث اي زلزال في
اسطنبول تبقى كبيره قياسا بالخسائر التي
يمكن ان تتسبب فيها فاسطنبول من بين المدن
الاكثر كثافه بالسكان في العالم حيث يقطن
بها اكثر من 16 مليون شخص وتتوقع دراسه ان
يلحق الزلزال الضرر
22% من مباني اسطنبول في حال حدوثه طبعا
وفي حال بلغت شدته 7.5 درجه وقد يتسبب في
وفاه 200 الف شخص وعلى مدى عقد كامل حذر
عدد من علماء الزلازل في تركيا من وقوع
زلزال مدمر في اسطنبول لانها تقع عند
تقاطع الصفائح التكتونيه الاناضوليه
والاوراسيه وهو عامل قد يجعلها منطقه
معرضه للزلازل
هي الاحياء والاف من قاطني بنايات وصف
عمده اسطنبول هياكلها بالخطيره
انها مساله حياه او موت هكذا حذرت سلطات
اسطنبول السكان هنا داعيه اصحاب البنايات
الهشه والقديمه الى الاسراع في فحسها
وهناخذ عينه علي تركي من اصول عربيه يعيش
بهذه البنايه المتصدعه في حي الفاتح منذ
سنوات في تشققات
الفاتح وعندي هون تشققات بس فوق وانا ما
بقول لك ما في خوف في خوف بس شلون الوضع
عم بطل مثلا اليوم صار شيء
كل ما يشغل باله هذه الايام هو كيفيه
انقاذ عائلته في حال تحركت الارض
والله يسترنا اذا كان وضع مثلا بدي يهدوا
يهدوا الحكومه تقرف مو انا بقرف على
اولادك شلون كل واحد خايف على اولادها غير
الله سبحانه وتعالى وهالاولاد
احصت بلديه اسطنبول ما يزيد عن 100 الف
بنايه بحاجه عاجله الى فحص ضوئي واوسط
باتخاذ قرارات صارمه لانقاذ ملايين
الارواح في ظل توقعات خبراء بحدوث زلزال
هائل خلال السنوات القادمه
نحن نتوقع ان يحدث زلزال اخر قد لا يكون
مركزه في اسطنبول لكنها ستتضرر كثيرا
خصوصا اننا لم نحضر جيدا لذلك فكثير من
البنايات غير مطابقه للزلازل ويجب اعاده
النظر سريعا في معايير البناء
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كان هذا عن تركيا اما في سوريا المناطق
المتضرره هناك لا تزال تنزف من اثار
الزلزال والدعوه باتت ملحه من اجل التحرك
لانقاذ الوضع ونظمه اطباء بلا حدود انضمت
الى المؤسسات الداعيه الى زياده مساعدات
انسانيه الى شمال غرب سوريا وذلك بشكل
عاجل ودعت منظمه اطباء بلا حدود في بيان
لها الى زياده الامدادات الانسانيه بشكل
عاجل كونها حاليا لا تنسجم حتى مع حجم ما
كانت عليه قبل وقوع الزلزال وتاتي هذه
الدعوه بالتزامن مع وصول قافله مكونه من
اربع عشره شاحنه تابعه للمنظمه لكنها تبقى
غير كافيه وذلك ما اكده رئيسه بعثه
المنظمه الى سوريا حكيم خالدي الذي اشار
الى ان المساعدات تاتي بكميات ضئيله في
الوقت الحالي
ولم يزل الزلزال الا من تعميق ازمه
الاعانات في المناطق الواقعه شمالي غرب
سوريا وقبل وقوع الكارثه كان نحو 90% من
سكان المناطق التي تعرضت للزلزال والخارجه
عن سيطره النظام تعتمد على المساعدات
وتسبب الزلزال في موجات نزوح جديده حيث
قالت منظمه اطباء بلا حدود ان هناك حوالي
180 الف نازح جديد في سوريا في عقب
الزلزال كما اكدت منظمه الامم المتحده ان
ما يزيد عن اربعه ملايين شخص بحاجه حاليا
الى المساعدات في شمال غرب سوريا
طبعا الان من ادلب دكتور عادل الدغيم مدير
مستشفى ادلب المركزي الدكتور اهلا بكم
معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه شكرا لكم
على تربيه دعوتنا بدايه كيف هو الوضع
الصحي عندكم في ادلب
نعم مساء الخير لك وللاخوه المشاهدين
بالنسبه للوضع الصحي الموجود حاليا في
شمال غرب سوريا بعد ان تعرضت المنطقه
للزلزال المدمر صراحه كنا نعاني من هشاشيه
في الوضع الصحي فيما قبل الزلزال واصبحنا
نعاني من عوز شديد في المعدات الطبيه
والاجهزه وخاصه بعد توافق اعداد كبيره من
المصابين الى المشافي المختلفه المكتشره
في شمال غرب سوريا واصبح الاطباء عجزون
امام هذه الاعداد الكبيره من المصابين هل
تلقيتم اي نوع من انواع المساعدات الطبيه
التي يمكن ان تخفف قليلا من هذا الوضع
دكتور عادل
صراحه وصلت الينا بعض المساعدات الطبيه
التي قام بها اطباء السوريون واعراض من
خلال بعثه الاطباء التي قدمت الينا
بالفتره الماضيه من الهلال الاحمر القطري
من منظمه التي قام بها اطباء السوريون في
امريكا وقاموا باحضار بعض المعدات الطبيه
ولكن حجم الكارثه الموجوده في شمال غرب
سوريا صراحه يفوق يفوق بكثير حجم هذه
المساعدات الطبيه المقدمه للمشاكل
الموجوده في شمال غرب سوريا دكتور اليوم
كان هناك تصريح لوزير الخارجي
نعم تفضل ما هي كنت اسالك هذا السؤال ما
هي اهم احتياجاتكم الان في المجال الصحي
دكتور عادل
صراحه نحن الان بحاجه الى مستهلكات ومعدات
طبيه مختلفه منها ما يتعلق باجهزه غسيل
الكليه والمواد اللازمه لها حيث اصبح قسم
كبير من المصابين يعانون من قصور الكلوي
نحن بحاجه الى ادويه التخدير الى ادويه
الالتهاب الى المعدات الطبيه المختلفه الى
المنافس الى اسره العنايه المشدده كما
اننا اصبحنا نواجه مشكله وجود اعداد كبيره
من المرضى المصابين بمرضى السرطان الذين
كنا نقوم بتحويلهم الى تركيا لتلقي العلاج
ولكن بعد حادثه الزلزال اصبحوا هؤلاء
المرضى يراجعون القسم الوحيد الموجود في
شمال غرب سوريا حاليا وهو في مشفى يعني
المركزي انتم بحاجه للمساعدات ليس فقط
المتعلقه بعلاج المصابين بسبب الزلزال
بالايضا لتقديم العلاجات المتعلقه
بالامراض المزمنه كذلك لانها يعني هي
حالات بحاجه للرع مستمره طيب دكتور اعذرني
يعني قبل ان ينتهي الوقت كنت اسالك الوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي تحدثها في زيارته اليوم
الى تركيا على انه العقوبات لم تمنع من
ايصال المساعدات الى الى سوريا
وجرى الحديث عن مجموعه اطباء امريكيين
تمكنوا من الدخول الى شمال غرب سوريا ربما
اشرت اليهم ربما هم في الاصل سوريون هلا
حدثتني عن طبيعه ما يقوم به الاطباء
الامريكيون في شمال غرب سوريا
الاطباء وهم غالبيتهم سوريون وبعض الاطباء
العرب الذين يعملون ضمن منظمه سامس قاموا
بزياره
المشافي الموجوده في شمال غرب سوريا قاموا
باجراء عدد لابسه من العمليات الجراحيه
للمصابين نتيجه الزلزال وقاموا بتقديم يد
المساعده ببعض المستهلكات والاجهزه الطبيه
التي التي استطاعوا احضارها معهم عبر
الحدود ولكن ما زلنا بحاجه الى المزيد من
هذه
المعدات والاجهزه الطبيه لان المستحقات
التي تصلنا يعني الدكتور عادل انت تقصد
بما تزال خجوله يعني هؤلاء الاطباء
الامريكيون يعني هم يعني هم بناء على عمل
تطوعي يعني ليس من جهه حكوميه ليس
الولايات المتحده التي ارسلتهم اليكم يعني
هم يعني من جانب تطوعي ارادوا ان يقدموا
الدعم
للمتضررين في سوريا صحيح
عمل عمل ذاتي عمل يعني عمل تطوعي وذاته
دفعهم واجبهم تجاه اليهم الموجودين في
شمال غرب سوريا كعمل انساني قاموا بتقديم
يد المساعده لنا تحيه لهم وتحيه لكم جميعا
انتم مفرد الطاقم الطبي الذين تعملون على
تقديم طبعا ما تستطيعون تقديمه للمتضررين
والمنكوبين الان
وبرجاء يعني نتمنى ان يكون ان تكون قناتنا
يعني وسيله لايصال صوتكم استمعنا من
خلالكم لما تحتاجون اليه من مساعدات الان
لعل وعسى تكون هناك استجابه قريبه جدا
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا على هذه المداخله معنا
الدكتور عادل دغيم انت مدير مستشفى ادلب
المركزي كنت معنا من ادلب
[موسيقى]
نقلت بلومبورج عن دبلوماسيين قولهم من
المراقبين الدوليين رصدوا في ايران
الاسبوع الماضي يورانيوم مخصب الى مستويات
تقترب من صنع سلاح النووي فقال
الدبلوماسيان دبلومبو ان اليورانيوم وصلت
درجه وقائه الى 84% وهو اعلى مستوى وجده
المفتشون في البلاد حتى الان حيث تحتاج
ايران الى زياده هذه النسبه بالسته بالمئه
فقط للوصول للسلاح النووي اي بدرجه نقاء
90%
وكان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو قد
قال ان اسرائيل لن تسمح لايران بامتلاك
اسلحه النوويه
ايران تحاول ايذاء اسرائيل ومواطنيها
اينما كانوا في العالم بلا هوادا هجمات
ايران لن تثبط عزيمتنا لن نسمح لايران
بامتلاك اسلحه نوويه ولا نسمح لها
بالتمركز على طول حدودنا الشماليه نفعل كل
شيء وسنبدو القصار جهدنا لحمايه مواطنينا
ونرد بشده على الهجمات ضدنا
قال السفير الولايات المتحده لدى اسرائيل
توم نادي ان الاتفاق النوويه مجمد حاليا
لان واشنطن لن تتفاوض مع طهران في الوقت
الذي تزود فيه روسيا بالطائرات المسيره
ووفق صحيفه
فان السفيره الامريكيه اضاف ان تهديدات
ايران النوويه ليست لاسرائيل فقط بل للشرق
الاوسط وامريكا مضيفا ان الان معتبره ان
ان هذا الوقت في الان ذاته عفوا في نفس
الوقت ان اسرائيل يمكنها ان تفعل كل ما
تريد للتعامل مع ايران مؤكدا مسانده
واشنطن لها
افادت وسالوا من اسرائيليه برفع قوات
البحريه لدرجه التاهب في البحر الاحمر
خوفا من هجوم ايران وقال التقارير
الاسرائيليه انه بعد استهداف سفن تابعه
لاسرائيل قبل ايام دفع البحريه لتوقع
هاجمات ايرانيه جديده في البحر الاحمر
خاصه ان ايران كثفت من وجودها هناك منذ
العام الماضي بوضع عناصر عسكريه على متن
سفن مدني
معنى من الناصره النظير مجلي المحلل
السياسي استاذ نظير اهلا بكم معنا هل
تعتقد حقا ان ايران كانت بصدد توجيهي
الضربه كبيره لاسرائيل ولذلك قامت اسرائيل
بشن الغاره على دمشق بالامس
او اليوم عفوا
استاذ نظير ضيفي تسمعني بشكل واضح
الان اسمعك انا نعم كنت سالتك هل تعتقد ان
ايران كانت ستوجه ضربه قاسيه لاسرائيل
ولذلك استبقتها اسرائيل
بتوجيه غاره في دمشق
يعني في اسرائيل طبعا لا يتحدثون بصراحه
عن انهم هم المسؤولون عن هذه الغاره ولكن
بالتلميح يقولون ان هذه ضربه جاءت ردا على
الضربه التي واجهتها ايران الى احدى السفن
التجاريه الاسرائيليه في الخليج والتي
اعلن عنها فقط يوم امس وهي جرت في الاسبوع
الماضي وكانت تلك ردا على عمليه اصفهان
التي نسبت الى اسرائيل فاسرائيل جاءت
ليتوجه هذه الضربه بسرعه حتى ترد اولا على
الضربه التي وجهت الى سفينتها يعني عمليا
ليس فقط السباق للماضي للمستقبل بينما هي
في الاساس رد على الضربه التي وجهت الخليج
نعم طيب ولكن هناك لم نفهم طبيعه هذه
الغاره التي شنتها اسرائيل صحيح هي لم
تعترف بها ولكن ضمنيا واضح يعني انه
اسرائيل وراءها
ما كانت تستهدف برايك هذه الغاره استاذ
نظير خاصه ان هناك بعض المصادر تتحدث عن
استهداف ربما قيادي كبير هناك في كفر سوسه
في دمشق
لا يوجد نفي لهذا الامر في اسرائيل بشكل
غير مباشر طبعا ولكن واضح انك اسماعيل
قراني رئيس الحرس الثوري الايراني موجود
في سوريا
واستهدفت الضربه مكانين المكان الاول هو
مكان تابع مباشره للقوات الايرانيه في
دمشق
واستهدف
[موسيقى]
في السويداء نعم لا يوجد ضربتان واحده
بالسويداء واخرى قرب دمشق الموقع الذي ضرب
قرب دمشق هو موقع ايراني يستخدمه تستخدمه
القوات الايرانيه المتواجده في سوريا
للامور اللوجستيه هذا ما تحدثوا عنه بهذه
المعلومات التي تم تسريبها وكان الهدف هو
ان توجه الضربه العينين ومباشره لهدف
ايران نعم طيب يعني في خضم يعني كل كل هذه
الاحداث هل تعتقد ان ايران
في وارد بالفعل ان توجه اي ضربه لاسرائيل
او هل هي قادره بالفعل على
تهديد اسرائيل كما توعدها بنيامين نتنياهو
اليوم
يعني مشكوك فيه ان يكون هناك رد اخر على
هذه الضربه لان هي محدوده باعتقادي وعاده
يعني ضربه مقابل ضربه ولكن هنالك حرب
مفتوحه بين اسرائيل وايران ان لم تضرب
ايران فاسرائيل ستضرب
واليوم يتحدثون عن تطور جديد في قضيه
النووي ان هنالك تقدم كبير في
التخصيب اليورانيوم لدى نسبه 84%
يفحصون الان اذا كان هذا مقصود او انها
مواد متراكمه داخل القنوات التي تم اكتشاف
هذا التطور فيها علما بان
قائد القائد الاسرائيلي لشعبه الاستخبارات
العسكريه هارون حذاء وكانت قد قال في شهر
نوفمبر الماضي قبل اربعه شهور عمليا ان
هنالك تطور جديد في التقدم نحو انه في
ايران وعندنا هنالك ما يكفي لهم من اعداد
اربعه قنابل نوويه والان يوجد وضع خطير
بانهم يعدون صواريخ
لتستطيع ان تضربه ان روسيا تقدم خدمات
لايران في هذا المجال وفي اسرائيل يتابعون
هذا الموضوع بالتنسيق مع الولايات المتحده
امس نتنياهو ايضا تحدث عن هذا التنسيق مع
الولايات المتحده ورؤيه الخطر في التطور
النووي الايراني نظير مجله مباشره من
الناصره شكرا جزيلا لك
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه فيسبوك تعلن عن
ميزه التوثيق مقابل الدفع
[موسيقى]
اعلن رئيس التنفيذي لشركه متر الملكه
لموقع فيسبوك مارك زوكربيرج عن اطلاق خدمه
تعطي لمشتركيها علامه التوثيق الزرقاء
وذلك على غرار ما فعله موقع تويتر خلال
الاشهر الماضيه كشف ان الخدمه تتيح
للمشتركيها الحصول على الشعره الزرقاء
والحصول على حمايه اضافيه ضد امتحان
الهويه من الحسابات المزيفه والوصول بشكل
مباشر وسريع الى دعم العملاء مضيفا انا
الاشتراك بالميزه الجديده سيكون ابتداء من
12 دولارا وحتى 15 دولارا وستنطلق من
نيوزيلندا واستراليا هذا الاسبوع ثم الى
بقيه العالم
اذا مشاهدينا بهذا الخبر من فيسبوك ناتي
الى ختام اخبار الساعه لهذا المساء شكرا
لكم على كرم المشاهده دائما للمزيد
العربيه دوت نت وكذلك صفحاتنا على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي تويتر فيسبوك ويوتيوب
وكذلك بامكانكم مسح هذا الرمز الظاهر الان
على الشاشه باستخدام الكاميرا الهاتف الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]